der hyper loop entwickelt sich in
windeseile das transportmittel der
zukunft das schneller als ein
verkehrsflugzeug durch eine röhre mit
einem teil vakuum rast ständig gibt es
neue tests pläne und pilotanlagen und
jetzt einen neuen rekord und den hat
nicht etwa ein amerikanisches team
aufgestellt sondern ausgerechnet ein
deutsches das wahnsinnige dabei
der rekord ist wirklich bahnbrechend und
überflügelt alle anderen teilnehmer um
ein vielfaches und ideengeber ihnen maas
hat jetzt noch eine neue idee hyper luke
der neue rekord und die neueste idee
jetzt den klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
damit haben außenstehende beobachter
wohl nicht gerechnet erstens dass es so
schnell mit dem projekt vorwärts geht
und zweitens das was jetzt in hawthorne
in kalifornien passiert ist es stand an
der zweite internationale hyper
wettbewerb auf der hyper lobte strecke
von spacex um das deutsche team musste
hohe erwartungen erfüllen schon beim
ersten wettbewerb im januar hatten die
münchner gewonnen sie erreichen damals
eine geschwindigkeit von 95 kilometern
pro stunde
damals hatten sich die 35 studierenden
aus elf nationen sogar gegen ein team
des renommierten m des massachusetts
institute of technology aus cambridge in
den usa durchgesetzt
auch das war schon ziemlich
beeindruckend denn eigentlich ist dieses
team einen freizeit arbeitskreis der das
projekt außerhalb der uni umgesetzt hat
war ist der name mit 2 r und es heißt
wissenschaftliche arbeitsgemeinschaft
für raketentechnik und raumfahrt und
wurde 1962 gegründet um den fehlenden
lehrstuhl für luft und raumfahrt zu
ersetzen die arbeitsgruppe startet erst
die erste deutsche break rakete
barbarella am 12 märz 1974 sie steht
heute im deutschen museum in münchen
dementsprechend groß war der druck und
eigentlich konnte sich niemand
vorstellen dass sie ihren erfolg
wiederholen würden bei einer solchen
neuen technologie spielen glück und
zufälle dann doch zu eine große rolle
dass ein studierenden team dann so
zuverlässig einen erfolg reproduzieren
kann ist dann doch nicht unbedingt zu
erwarten insbesondere weil das team um
neue studierende erweitert wurde und
einen vollkommen neuen also
das hyper luftfahrzeug konstruiert hatte
aber es passierte das unerwartete
die studierenden der technischen
universität münchen brachten es zum
zweiten mal in die runde der letzten
drei und da stellten sie alle anderen in
den schatten während das
drittplatzierte team swiss flug von der
eth zürich gerade einmal auf 39
stundenkilometer kam und der
zweitplatzierte das team der
universitäten aus kann aber auf 104
kilometer pro stunde kam das team waren
aus münchen in der 125 kilometer lange
röhre auf unglaubliche 324 km pro
stunde
innerhalb von drei sekunden wurde der
pott dann abgebremst auch eine
technologische meisterleistung wahnsinn
ihnen moskva dementsprechend verblüfft
so schnell war kein port vorher und
jetzt präsentiert maske eine neue idee
warum nicht auch elektroautos in der
röhre transportieren die wagen würden
einfach in die röhre gesteckt und
könnten auch ohne den luftwiderstand im
teil vakuum unglaubliche
geschwindigkeiten erreichen
also es bleibt spannend beim hyper lud
wenn er kein video zum thema und zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann sollten wir hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesslich denen auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit hyper lobt
deutsche strecke geplant ein klick und
er war ihr erfahrt mehr über dieses
thema ansonsten bis dann